[Musique]
les jeux de légumes sont toujours aussi
populaires on le voit par l'offre en
épicerie c'est pratique dans les boîtes
à lunch les collations sur le pouce mais
souvent on ne reproché à ces produits là
d'être trop salé les fabricants longs
compris ils proposent des versions
allégées en sodium ici ce qu'on fait
goûter aujourd'hui à nos participants
nous avons choisi trois produits de
marque nationale V8 le mode et le oasis
et un produit de great value du salon de
la moto au Palais des congrès de
Montréal place à la dégustation
ce sont tous des cocktails de légumes
réduits en sel vous en buvez des fois
déjà à la maison
plus maintenant mais pas très bien
est-ce que vous regardez ça la teneur en
sodium
quand tu manges mieux tu vis mieux
les fabricants veulent réduire le sel
dans leur produit par contre c'est un
défi gustatif le sel ça goûte bon ça
rehausse le goût des produits alors les
produits qui sont réduits en sel on voit
les travailler autrement on va jouer un
petit peu plus justement avec le sucre
parce que qui dit réduire le sel =
réduire aussi le goût de façon générale
on retrouve dans des agents de
conservation donc ça peut être de
l'acide ascorbique pour la vitamine C
mais ça peut être aussi des ingrédients
qui vont venir jouer sur le goût du
produit donc du jus de citron ça peut
être du vinaigre ça peut être aussi des
réhausseurs de goût et on a des additifs
alimentaires dans un produit qu'on
pourrait penser que c'est tout
simplement des légumes mais ce n'est pas
le cas
[Musique]
pour le oasis on a une liste
d'ingrédients qui est plus épurée donc
pas de sucre ajouté dans ce produit là
uniquement le sucre qui est en
provenance des légumes dans la majorité
des jus de légumes ce qu'on trouve après
ma base c'est soit de la pente ou de la
purée de tomate donc c'est vraiment le
légume principal qu'on retrouve dans ces
jus là après ça il peut y avoir une
variété de jus ça peut des jus même des
concentrés de jus de légumes ça fait du
persil ça peut être la carotte de
l'oignon du poivron vert du cresson de
la betterave donc dans tous les produits
on retrouve une majorité de ces légumes
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui est salé vraiment plus de légumes on
dirait
quelque chose de plus naturels
[Rires]
qui ont été retenus pour le test de goût
il y en a trois qui sont autour de 135
140 mg de sodium par portion donc ce qui
est tout à fait convenable il y en a un
donc le great value qui est à 320 mg de
sodium par portion et ça ça fait partie
de ceux pour qui la version originale la
quantité de sodium est très élevée alors
c'est certain que même si on réduit de
moitié la quantité de sel il en demeure
quand même une quantité importante dans
le produit réduit en sel
[Musique]
donc ce produit là improbablement un
goût beaucoup plus relevé que la moyenne
c'est un bon supplément un bon
supplément de légumes quand on mange des
légumes frais on vient consommer des
fibres on vient mastiquer le légume donc
ça rentre dans notre estomac ça prend de
la place un jus de légumes c'est
principalement du jus donc on a vraiment
retiré la fibre des légumes et on ajoute
à ça de la pâte ou de la purée de tomate
donc oui un petit peu de fibres mais
tout est broyé alors non ça sera jamais
la même chose de consommer un jus de
légumes lorsqu'on compare à des légumes
frais
plus ça écoute plus peut-être les
carottes plus terne d'une certaine façon
le jus de légumes V8 contient du jus de
raisin fait de concentré donc c'est une
façon différente de nous dire que du
sucre ajouté dans le produit il y a
aussi un assaisonnement et de la saveur
donc un arôme qui est ajouté aux
produits alors on espère combler les
papilles des consommateurs qui vont
boire se produire réduit en sodium
il reste quand même des vitamines à
l'intérieur des minéraux je pense que ça
peut être un produit qui est utilisé
couramment quand on a besoin d'une
solution le pratique sur la route là
pour consommer nos légumes
les gens ont semblé apprécier les
versions réduites en sodium qu'on leur a
proposé aujourd'hui il y a peut-être de
nouvelles habitudes d'achat qui sont en
train de se dessiner quand on regarde
les résultats on voit qu'il y a eu une
chose lutte entre le great value et le
oasis mais c'est moi ce qui l'emporte
avec 20 votes merci à nos bouteurs et
nos gouttes
[Applaudissements]